but we have a fascinating book review by
a fascinating man Jack hoppers and
economic consultants have been on
alternative views for a long time you've
been reading a book called Trading
Places about our friends who
inadvertently won world war two after
all Trading Places by Clyde Presta wits
check this out of the public library
right well now you have a PhD in
economics and all you've been doing
economic consulting this must be right
up your alley
well I'm PhD is in international
economics as a matter of fact so the
whole issue of international trade
international economics is a matter of
great interest to me but even more so is
the view of what's happening in the
economy you can't you can hardly buy
some things that are Japanese made and
so that that bridge brings the
interesting question forward what's
taking place here this particular writer
and this book poses the issue pretty
squarely that we have simply allowed the
Japanese to move in and take over the
lead that we had in trade and
manufacturing particularly manufacturing
and if we don't do something about it we
are going to be in bad trouble
well are we in bad trouble right now yep
we're going to be a lot worse trouble if
we don't do something about this even
though our deficit trade with Japan is
sixty billion dollars a year what's
happened is that these people the
Japanese have targeted certain
industries one by one to take over from
us and they are doing it and in the name
of national interest in power and of
course eventually we're going to wind up
with the Japanese telling us and setting
for us the policy that we're going to be
exercising in the world and domestically
can you give us an idea of how this has
happened step by step well first you got
to realize that there were there were
things cause I bought suit before World
War two the Japanese had these combines
and these combines ran things they ran
the government they didn't run the
military and that
that was a little bit of context that
they had Mike Arthur
thought he eliminated these zaibatsu and
that was a combination of banks and
trading companies and industrial outfits
all right they were huge combines that
there were there were self-sufficient
almost well these are BOTS who have come
back and there's a boxer or what's
competing with us and of course there's
not any free trade when the Japanese
government supports the zaibatsu around
the world and so they have simply moved
into the United States taking over steel
well along taking over automobiles to
machine tools all sorts of electronic
equipment and the next target is
computers and IBM and we don't do
something about the way they're
operating they're going to drive IBM Oh
business well let me get some historical
perspective here you mentioned that the
zaibatsu one of the big things that the
United States was going to do after
World War 2 was to break the power of
these big Zaibatsu and to make the
Japanese industry and commercial system
competitive they've had any trust laws
and they permitted unions for the first
time and the multiplicity of political
parties MacArthur was there to run it
however I saw fascinating article in
far-eastern reviews several years ago
where it turns out that the large
American banks investment banks Wall
Street firms worked over a period of
time to undermine these reforms which
MacArthur was instituting and carrying
out and over a period of time through
government action and through economic
international action they were able to
do away with these reforms and get their
people back into power in Japan and get
the old establishment back in power and
the reason they did this was because
these u.s. Wall Street firms had
relationships and joint ventures with
the Japanese before World War two
and so they were wanting to reestablish
these relationships and get the gravy
train coming back they didn't want any
of this competition this antitrust and
unions coming in so this is this is some
interesting background how the the
international banking community got
these guys reestablished oppressed which
is he talked about what he doesn't and
and in fact he has a different theory
that makes more sense than that one now
that one may have had there may have
been some part to play but he makes the
argument that the occupation people
didn't speak Japanese didn't understand
the culture didn't know anything about
the Japanese and simply allowed the same
Japanese civil service and bureaucracy
to continue running things during the
occupation and later as he did before
and of course they were Zaibatsu trained
and the MacArthur and his people didn't
even know what they were doing and so
immediately after the occupation was
over and during the Korean War when we
force-fed Japanese industry to rebuild
based on the need to sell and the build
and the support that war like that we
were out of there and immediately of
course the system began to restore
itself now there may have been some part
to play that that took place on the
international scale with international
banks and whatnot but this man doesn't
doesn't give that very much credence
they're probably both going on probably
was but he places the most important
role of this process to simply the fact
that that the same people continued to
do it and they had every intention as
soon as my car that was out out of the
way to restore the system and they put
it in place and as soon as he was gone
they restored it Jack one of the things
you mentioned was that today Japan has
achieving leadership in the computer and
communications industry and this has
grave implications for our national
security as well as our own industrial
development you want to go into this in
some detail it's sort of interesting if
we're going to have to build rockets and
then have the Japanese put the the
guidance systems in and in five or ten
years that's that's where we're headed
of course because the the computer chip
business the semiconductor business that
we invented and that we developed we
have lost in fact Trading Places really
deals
with a semiconductor industry which has
lost out to the Japanese we have traded
places with the Japanese in terms of our
ascendancy it's sort of interesting of
course you go on to that particular in
that particular industry right now in
the news is the discussion of the fact
that the Japanese are making the first
inroads into our aircraft industry they
refuse to buy of 16 aircraft and so we
are about to cave in with them and do a
cooperative deal with them and give them
our technology General Dynamics is going
to give them the technology and they're
in effect going to invent their own web
air weaponry and commercial air system
and they're going to take over from
Boeing and McDonnell Douglas that's the
next step and and that issue is
partially unresolved because we haven't
decided whether we're going to give them
all the technology or just some of the
technology right now
Jack the the precedent for this was set
in the electronics industry where the
u.s. invented television even VCRs it's
little known that it was an American
firm in 1970 that created the first VCR
for the home market but it was never
marketed or developed here it was sold
to the Japanese and since then all
televisions all VCRs most electronics
are made in Japan they have the key
patents that are the ones that actually
produce this so the same think it easily
happen in the computer microchip
semiconductor industry where the u.s.
again played the leading role in
developing these technologies but then
they slowed down and the Japanese have
appeared to be at least taking over just
like they did electronic well the
Japanese government and the Japanese
zaibatsu are one mine one purpose and of
course they divide and conquer with each
country and with each industry in this
country of course we can't we we have no
coherent policy each one of these
industries can be picked off each one of
these companies is being picked off and
one by one the Japanese power
concentrated power is picking them all
off and meanwhile we have these fools
these these nitwits who run our foreign
policy and our trade policy who say hey
free trade free trade meanwhile the
Japanese are just taking advantage
free trade by wiping out what few
traders are left and we don't seem to be
able to understand that eventually this
this free trade thing is going to drive
us to the point where our security is
going to be at risk we are spending so
much time worrying about the Communist
menace
we had better worry about the Japanese
Menace well Jack it's I don't I hadn't
read the book so I didn't know what if
he does he get involved in how
intertwined a lot of US businesses and
finance capital are where the Japanese
for instance I remember a few years ago
when US Steel you know we just can't
compete we're going to have to shut down
plants because the Japanese are doing so
much better etc before we can't compete
with a foreign low-wage system yet on
the other hand I read in some other
articles where US Steel was investing in
steel plants overseas and also in Japan
plus the fact that the US banks which
also had most of the stock of US Steel
and had directors on the board of u.s.
steel were also investing in Japanese
steel at the same time they were running
down the u.s. steel industry well this
man has a different view of it now this
man right here has a lot of experience
and he makes a very persuasive case in
his case is the Japs don't do business
with anybody with Japanese Japanese do
not go into partnership with anybody
else and to the extent that they allow a
certain amount of investment or a
certain amount of marketing it's just a
salt they got no intentions of truly
doing that on any kind of a a systematic
basis because they don't do business
with with foreigners except to get their
money they don't believe in having
associations with people outside of the
Japanese the Japanese culture calls
today although if they need foreign
capital and investment it makes perfect
sense to open their markets to this kind
of investment from US multinationals as
long as they can control it but they
haven't done that I mean that's the
whole problem they refuse to do that
they haven't had to they haven't had to
because the way the government operates
it allows these people who have
extremely high
leverage businesses extremely low risk
and extremely low-cost interest loans
and it what has happened is that the
Japanese system meaning the combination
of the of the government and the
Zaibatsu has eliminated risk for most of
these businesses as a matter of fact
most Japanese businesses make a lower
rates return do not do as well as
American companies because they don't
emphasize profit they emphasize growth
and what they're looking for is market
share and growth and once they get their
market share and growth they drive their
competitors out of business and then
they make what they want to because they
set the price then the way they want to
well now the US manufacturers have
bought into this system for their own
profit because you take the shell take
the body off of the US car and you'll
find Japanese made components all the
way through as it is the coat the coat
is a Japanese car that Chrysler is
importing that's right that that takes
place but once again that's a whole car
every that's a whole car but I mean
every car most every car you buy the
components inside various components are
going to eat Japanese well certainly the
electronic components are certainly
going to be plus the fact that the tire
is probably will be - if the General
Motors or or no I think it's a Chrysler
that has I think 50 percent ownership
and a joint venture with Isuzu so the
American multinationals are involved in
this as well yes they don't see this is
a danger at all we know and the
interesting part is yeah those
combination companies sell into this
market but they don't sell in the
Japanese market I said there is no
market most home market absolute
ventures as well as a means of
penetration absolutely foreign markets
and they're moving into the common
market right now and the common market
had enough sense to realize that what
they did in the United States was
something they could do in in Europe and
and they're they're trying to put some
barriers on them and they're making a
lot more sense with their trade policy
and than we did this man makes a kit
makes the case that if we don't do
something about it if we don't make some
moves
and we sit by like the Reagan
administration did over the last eight
years and let this situation continue
we're all going to be frying hamburgers
for a McDonald's owned by Japanese
zaibatsu and we're going to be serving
those hamburgers to Japanese tourists
and that's all we're going to be doing
Jack what sorts I mean that's no
exaggeration because that's what the
argument he makes the the the term now
is D industrialized post industrialized
Society and the Republicans are saying
isn't this wonderful we're in a service
economy yeah but the service economy is
going to be long to the Japanese and
they're going to be the only ones with
money to buy the service I mean it goes
further than the fact that we're going
to de industrialize and we're going to
be a service economy we're not even
going to own our service economy we're
going to own it and we're going to be
providing them with the services they're
the only ones they're going to have
money if this thing continues the way
this man makes the argument that that is
continuing well what would be the
government and industry response that
would prevent this Japanese takeover
well his argument is twofold one is
we've got to begin to centralize and
make sense out of a trading policy over
and over and over industries have
brought a suit under unfair trade
practices and dumping the whole issue of
dumping and the Japanese have bought off
enough American lobbyists and have
penetrated certain trade associations to
neutralize those I mean it may be too
late but if the administration doesn't
get a unified act together of
understanding what is best in this
country and free trade is certainly not
best it's obvious then it's going to
continue the alternative of course the
or the other piece of this was our
foreign trade deficit is creating some
of these problems too and of course are
the regular domestic deficit is allowing
the Japanese to buy up the country as it
goes along and the more the Japanese buy
in the more control they're going to
exercise politically and they are
exercising political control now that
goes beyond the Israelis it goes beyond
the Arabs because they've got so much
money to spend and they're so rational
with it and they've bought so many
revived
door administration people that it's
it's a real question is whether whether
we can reverse it now or not Jack I
think there is a clever Republican
rationale for that for this whole policy
and that is that the reason one of the
reasons they give to have this free
trade policy so-called
is that it means lower consumer prices
so that if the public can buy more goods
at lower prices they're happier because
that's what they've been taught is the
route to happiness through the consumer
society so this makes people happy with
Republican policies well and they're
just unaware of what the long-term
implications are that what's behind this
that has been true and that is a
short-term aspect but but obviously
we've had national security interests
that have come forward the Pentagon has
been concerned about this for some time
the truth really is that this man makes
a very persuasive argument that we're
going to wind up as a colony a colony of
Japan and I remember there was a colony
that they took over from from China
called Manchuria they renamed it Manchu
coal and I wonder what they would rename
the United States once they took it over
well there's something of a historical
nature that I'd like to ask you and that
is in the United States when we had we
have these big monopolies and
oligopolies tick industries where they
drive out competitors except for a
couple of buddies who are working with
them as a result we got high prices and
inferior products but the Japanese have
set up monopolies at home but they seem
to have superior products now how what's
the difference how come they have
quality from their monopoly and we have
inferior well you name two things your
name quality and you name price the
Japanese consumer pays 50% more for
Japanese products than the American
consumer but the same product absolutely
you mean a VCR absolutely yes more than
here Oh far more they're dumping them in
this country oh that's right dumping
them I saw them over the Japanese
consumer is a sheep I mean over there
the zaibatsu meaning the business
interests were on every
including politics the Japanese died is
is in effect under the tight control of
these government agencies the top
ministries serve their part their
Parliament is under the control of the
government ministries and the zaibatsu
and therefore all policy is designed to
further the the national interest which
is power and that's what it was in the
pre-war deal the the truth really is
that Japanese had not changed any over
the last 100 years the Japanese culture
continues to look down on all foreigners
the Japanese culture continues to to see
themselves as supermen the Japanese
culture continues to place everybody in
the inferior position they do not teach
all the horror stories of World War two
the Japanese are still hated throughout
Europe I mean Asia because they treated
the other Asian so bad during World War
Two that they're still and repulsion all
over the all over the system over there
and of course I think we forget about
The Rape of Nanking we forget about the
sneak attack on Pearl Harbor we forget
that the Doolittle Raiders who were
captured in the raid on Tokyo were
captured and beheaded and we forget how
many how many prisoners were allowed to
starve to death we forget the the
barbaric nature of the Japanese only not
not because they're necessarily
barbarians but because they think all
foreigners are inferior and therefore
they can treat them like like dirt they
they could have taught Hitler about the
master race well the size and strength
of the Japanese economy in relationship
to the United States what is that now
well the population is 120 compared to
our 240 it's only about half and I don't
have numbers on the gross national
product but it's certainly creeping up
there well I know they have the largest
banks now by far and they're there
they're there equivalent of our tharok
stock stock exchange is considerably
larger yes it's obvious that they
wouldn't be anywhere near like that if
it did have
our markets because it's a very small
country really not only that but they've
got a relatively weak still got a
relatively low standard living sure the
cost of living over there can be
extremely horrifying if you have to go
over there and serve but if you look at
the kind of advantages the Japanese
people on the whole have there they're
still not very good their homes are
small they have to commute three and
four hours to work things are extremely
expensive over there even for the people
that have cradle to the grave jobs with
a zaibatsu and they work my gosh they
work you know twelve sixteen hours a day
particularly the Middle East I could
even like that they just dry there was
an article somebody wrote they called on
the assembly line at Toyota we are
driven and it showed how hard they
worked their workers but they seem to
know it's interesting that the Japanese
plans that have been built in this
country are are being built on a
colonial scale by that the local
businesses are controlled tightly out of
out of Japan and they're authoritarian
they're not union of course and the
workers are treated just like Japanese
workers and it's it's not going to work
very good if if that's what we expect in
a way of manufacturing is for the
Japanese come over here and give us jobs
because we're not going to like the way
the Japs are going to treat us the
Japanese don't look at American workers
as they look on Japanese workers they
have a different attitude well know what
can be done now some people say well we
got to put up trade barriers and maybe
quotas so that the voters but they're
dead wrong with putting portals in
automobiles and all it did was make the
Japanese rich because they got the price
increase well if you're going to do
things like that you got to put tariffs
on there if you put a tariff on the
difference between the the cost imported
and the cost of sale the government take
our government takes it the Japanese
manufacturer doesn't take that but
that's not the answer
that may be part of the answer even
tariffs aren't because they increase the
tariffs about what happens it just means
the u.s. car manufacturers for instance
immediately raise the price of their
cars and we still get the same old lousy
quality of American cars at a higher
price so what is the solution well part
of the solution has got to be to
recognize the problem in the air and to
eliminate this nonsense about free trade
being Nirvana and that's what the Reagan
administration did they they just
wouldn't talk about anything that
smacked of limiting the Japanese ability
to invade this country they wouldn't
wouldn't consider it and then we got
begin to I wonder what the effects are
going to be what's it going to lead to
what is it led to where is it going to
lead and what's it going to take to stop
it one thing it's going to take to stop
it is are some policies that either
require them to open up their markets
and to do for our businesses what we
allow them to do over here or shut them
down I mean it may it may cost us money
the consumer may not be able to get all
the stuff he wants for all the price but
sooner or later he's going to wind up
with with almost no choices domestically
if this continues there is another thing
I'd like to ask you about and as I've
read where the Japanese are actually
buying up enormous areas of the third
world like in Mexico they're actually
you know the Japanese is a small country
but they're buying up huge tracts of
land for agriculture in other countries
well the Japanese have such a trade
surplus everywhere with everybody that
it's not a wonder that they have surplus
money in every country I mean the truth
is that not only are our manufacturers
finding it impossible to sell the
Japanese market everybody else is
finding the same problem with Japanese
simply exclude all foreigners they're
not they're not discriminating against
us they just don't like any foreigner
don't let any old man and so they run
trade surpluses therefore they can buy
all sorts of real estate and everything
else in every country in the world what
they couldn't do with a military
approach they can do with an economic
approach they've got their Greater East
Asia co-prosperity sphere all over the
country were prosperous beer they they
don't live in it this these days just to
East Asia anymore